so we've just had a meeting with Mark
Harper and his team
um I would say there's a positive
meeting in the sense that we've got rid
of the bellicose nonsense that we used
to head from Grant chaps and his cohort
in in his era
and we're now starting to get a dialogue
so
what we're hoping for and what Mr Harper
is committed to is giving us an outcome
from this meeting which will be a letter
to me saying how he sees us going
forward and taking forward steps towards
a resolution
and we laid out in what we thought he
should do and he's acknowledged some of
that and what we're chiefly asking him
to do you've heard him say that he's
going to be a facilitator towards a
settlement or a resolution at a dispute
and we've said to him it's no good
having these warm words we've heard them
uh from his predecessor Anne Marie's
Rebellion but nothing actually happened
so we want him to sit down in writing
what he's going to do about the
mechanics of how a resolution will be
facilitated because we've at the moment
we've got even got doubt about the
authority of the people we're speaking
to who were called The Rail delivery
group and they are telling us they have
no authority to to negotiate they do not
have a mandate and they've even put
legal challenges to us as to whether
they can negotiate at all so we've got a
situation where 14 train operating
companies are telling us they can't
negotiate and so is their Industry Group
the rail delivery group so I've asked
him to set out in writing and clarify
what the authority of these people is
and I've asked him to create a liaison
group or liaison Forum however they term
it at ministerial level so that the
industry and ourselves as trade unions
can go and see them or at least liaise
with them about how a settlement could
come about and we've also said to them
we need Pace in these negotiations I'm
sure the public the traveling public and
the businesses around the country and
the economy wants to see this dispute
settled in a proper way but we need Pace
six months we've been negotiating at
least with the train operators and we've
had not one document put across the
table that has to change and I outline
to him what his responsibilities are as
we see them and his responsibilities are
legally in the contracts they have with
these train operators he's got a legal
responsibility for industrial relations
and a responsibility to set their
mandate I.E what they can say what they
can offer and what they can negotiate on
at that table
so I'm hoping he's going to do that
hopefully today and we can get back to
the table as he's been demanded in the
media uh from me and from my union but
he needs to clarify him writing exactly
where he stands and where the industry
stands when they are uh you know
transacting with us in those discussions
so they need a new position they need a
new mandate and hopefully we can get on
with it and we'll be looking to do that
immediately we'll be talking to network
rail in the morning and as soon as the
rail delivery group invite us over we'll
be getting on with that so that's where
we are at the moment it's up to him now
to give us some documentation about how
we're going to carry this forward